what is the most beautiful idea in
physics
the most beautiful idea in physics is
that we can get a compact description of
the world that's
very precise and very full
at the level of the operating system of
the world
that's an extraordinary gift
and we get we get worried when we
uh have find discrepancies between
our uh description of the world and and
what's actually observed
at the level even of a part in a billion
you actually have this quote
from einstein that the the most
incomprehensible thing
about the universe is it's co is that it
is comprehensible something like that
yes that's so that's the most beautiful
surprise that i think
uh that that really was the
to me the most profound result of the
scientific revolution of this
of the 17th century with uh
the shining example of newtonian physics
that you could
aspire to completeness precision
and a concise description of the world
of the operating system
and it's gotten better and better over
the years
and that's the continuing miracle now
there are a lot of beautiful
sub-miracles too
the form of the equations is governed by
high degrees of symmetry
and and they have a very surprising kind
of mind-expanding structure especially
in quantum mechanics
but if we have if i have to say that the
single most
beautiful revelation is that
in fact uh the world is comprehensible
would you say that's a fact or hope it's
a fact
we can do we you can point to things
like
uh the rise of
uh gross
pro gross national products growth you
know per capita
around the world as a result of the
scientific revolution you can see it all
around you
uh in in recent developments with
exponent
so exponential production of wealth
control of nature
at a very profound level
where we do things like sense tiny tiny
tiny tiny vibrations
to tell that there are black holes
colliding far away
or we uh test laws as i
alluded to whether to pardon a billion
and do
you know things and what appear on the
surface to be entirely different
conceptual universes i mean on the one
hand
pencil and paper or nowadays computers
that calculate abstractions and on the
other hand
magnets and accelerators and detectors
that look at the behavior of fundamental
particles and
and these different universes have to
agree
or else we get very upset and that's uh
yeah it's an amazing thing if you think
about it so and
it's telling us that we do understand
a lot about nature at a very profound
level
and uh there are still things we don't
understand of course
but as we get better and better answers
and better and better
ability to address difficult questions
we can ask
more and more ambitious questions well i
guess the hope
part of that is because we are
surrounded by mystery
so we've one way to say it if you look
at the growth the
gdp over time that we figure out quite a
lot and we're
able to improve the quality of life
because of that
and we've figured out some fundamental
things about this universe but we still
don't know how much mystery there is
and it's also possible that there's some
things that are in fact
incomprehensible to both our minds
and the tools of science like we the
the sad things we may not know it
because
in fact they are incomprehensible and
that's the open question is
how much of the universe is
comprehensible if we figured out
the the everything uh what's inside the
black hole
and everything that happened at the
moment of the big bang
does that still give us the key to
understanding the human mind
and the emergence of all the beautiful
complexity we see around us
that's not uh like when i when i see
these objects like
i don't know if you've seen them like
cellular automata uh
all these kinds of objects where the
from simple rules emerges complexity yes
it makes you wonder maybe it's not
reducible to simple beautiful
equations the whole thing only parts of
it
that's the tension i was getting at with
the hope well
when we say the universe is
comprehensible we have to
kind of draw careful distinctions about
or
uh definitions about what
what we mean by by that uh both the
universe and the con
and the comprehensive exactly right so
the so in
certain areas of understanding uh
reality
we've made extraordinary progress i
would say
in understanding fundamental physical
processes
and getting very precise equations that
really work
and allow us to do the profound
sculpting of matter
you know to make computers and iphones
and everything else and they really work
and their extraordinary productions
uh on the other but
uh and that's all based on the laws of
quantum mechanics and you know they
really
and they really work and then uh
and they give us tremendous control of
nature
on the other hand uh as i said as we as
we get better answers we can also ask
more ambitious questions and there are
certainly things that
have been observed even in the
in what would be usually called the
realm of physics that aren't understood
for instance uh there seems to be
another source of mass in the universe
the so-called dark matter
that we don't know what it is and it's a
very interesting question what it is
uh then uh but also
as you were alluding to there there's
it's one thing to know the basic
equations it's another thing to be able
to solve them
in in important cases so we run a
we run up against the limits of that in
things like
chemistry where we'd like to be able to
design molecules and predict their
behavior
from the equations we think the
equations could do that
in principle but but uh
in in practice it's very challenging to
solve them in
in all but very simple cases uh
and then there's the other thing which
is that a lot of what we're interested
in
is uh historically conditioned it's not
uh it's not a matter of the fundamental
equations but about
what has evolved or come out
of of the early universe and formed into
people and frogs and societies and
things
and the laws of physics the basic laws
of physics only take you so far
in the in that it kind of provides a
foundation but doesn't
really that you need entirely different
concepts to deal with
uh those kind of uh systems and
all we one thing i can say about that is
that the laws themselves
point out their limitations that they
kind of their laws for dynamical
evolution so they tell you what happens
if you have a certain starting point but
they don't tell you what the starting
point
should be at least yeah and uh
the other the other thing that emerges
from the equations themselves
is the phenomena of chaos and
sensitivity to initial conditions which
tells us that uh you have
that there are intrinsic limitations on
how well we can
spell out the consequences of the laws
if we try to apply them
the old apple pie if you want to what
does it make an apple pie
from scratch it you have to build the
universe or something like that
well you're much better off starting
with apples than starting with quarks
let's put it that way
you